always bring us some of the best
moments after all
the action on Sunday and so is
we wind down here on peacock
let's
hear from coach Snoop as he
steps in sodium
hey hey hey what's going on
y'all now exciting weekend NFL
week 10 is in the books taking
questions right now feel free
to ask
your bacteria does the Bills win
today mean that they're
back on track the Bills win was
merely they play the Jets what
would you say to the Lions to
motivate them to get their first
win of the Season which
two teams will be I would like
to be politically correct in
saying La in Pittsburgh that
makes sense there's
a lot of interest in coaching in
the NFL teams has got to be
the coach that's willing to take
a chance on somebody like
me to put me in the position
that you know exercise my
skills go to Urban Meyer that's
crazy I wouldn't take that
job I give it to my homeboy Lil
Duval
Tupac so many teams going for it
on fourth down this season
in the NFL team goes for it on
4th down I'm an offensive
coordinator so I feel like I
don't bring no punters to
the table no way we can pack a
puncher so shout out
to all the teams going for it on
fourth down and punished
don't take it personal we don't
need you or boxing match
comes out on top and that's my
first time hearing about that
Frank Gore vs Jarren Williams at
point guard you split
the Mavericks
I'm going to go with Franklin
Delano Gore cuz it's Frankie D
went to the University of Miami
don't know he got some going in
there 305 in the house what did
they rename the Washington
football team 10 go-go music is
big in d.c.
so maybe the Washington Go-Go's
I heard a rumor that you and Ray
Mike play baby shark at
the Super Bowl halftime show
baby shark baby shark good to
the one NFL rule what would it
be
no drug test is there any other
questions
well I be having for dinner
tonight I will be having
a bologna sandwich with BBQ
chips say man y'all stay locked
and loaded and see you guys next
week week 11 y'all stay
safe keep it like right here on
your face